i was talking to a friend and i was
basically like
the you know the banality of evil is
this idea that like
just following orders okay right i'm not
i can't i'm not
well versed enough on the full you know
thesis the book and all that stuff but
the general idea my understanding is
that
when somebody like a nazi concentration
nazi guard
says i'm just following orders and they
care to carry out these atrocities
yeah they're doing these evil things but
it's you know banality
it's not like they're you know and
they're like it's it's not cobra where
they're all like you know
yeah it's just regular people who are
like i'll do whatever
it's like when when you see a cop
enforce an unconstitutional
order they don't care they'll just do it
and then you see it across this country
it's evil acts carried out by people who
aren't paying attention and don't care
and so i think about you know what's
going on
with i was talking to a friend about
these protesters and how
they're kind of destabilizing things at
home
they're attacking trump and i was
thinking like
i don't know if it's a lesser of two
evils but if trump is taking action to
pull us out of afghanistan
and he's targeting china that's our best
hope
of ending this genocide and he's trying
to end
trafficking of humans yeah so those are
two huge
things but these people he's open about
but what are the complaints they have
about him
that he's racist he's corrupt no they
say he's corrupt he's enriching himself
they do say that he's racist too sure
sure that's a that's a but
i mean a few i mean trust me i've been
in the middle of
trying to explain myself to many many
people and that's one of the
that is actually that is the number one
thing that everybody comes to me
well how can you support such a racist i
don't know
i mean i don't i think he is i mean i
mean the argument right when they say
he's racist i say i don't care you know
why even if donald trump was a racist
okay if he's trying to pull our troops
back i will take four years of a racist
president if it means no more war in the
middle east
i i don't i don't believe that he is
racist i don't know i don't either
but i was thinking about like the
banality of evil
these people who are out screaming and
protesting and trying to put biden
in power and biden was part of the
administration that bolstered
the war front in the middle east and
north africa and and the police military
state that we have here
yeah absolutely absolutely like that was
and black lives matter protests started
under
obama and biden and they want all that
back exactly i'm not going to pretend
like trump is
is good but i'm sorry that like he's a
saint
right but there's a few key things that
i think are
good like ending the war going after
china for their atrocities
definitely trafficking like ending
trafficking and he he did right by the
economy and those are really important
things so for all the criticisms you
might have that he's racist he's bigoted
he's a loudmouth braggart lascivious i'm
like yeah that's all
true but i think about the net positives
and i think about your choice right now
you have joe biden
who literally is on camera groping young
girls
and sniffing them and then you complain
about trump okay well joe biden takes
that cake baby
and well what about you know trump is
war it's like actually there's no new
wars under trump and joe biden
he takes that cake baby yeah and so you
want to talk about money laundering and
emoluments
and racism oh yeah you want to dig into
biden's past about being racist
wow i i went through i went down that
rabbit hole
i i just i just look i put it this way
i said do you i was talking to my friend
i was like do you know what hap what's
going on right now in china
and they didn't know yeah and so i sent
the ap article where it says that
china's force
sterilizing people i didn't even show
the forced organ harvesting yet but i
ended up sending her the forced
organizers thing and she was like i
didn't know about this
and i said joe biden flew with his son
to china and his son got a private
equity deal for like a billion dollars
he got like a contemporary 1.5
1.5 got he got 10 stake in some private
equity firm or something like that
and i was like you can talk about trump
flying over these countries and doing a
lot of things too but right now
trump is absolutely in conflict with
china absolutely
and i was like what about afghanistan
should we be over there
and it's funny to me how many of my
liberal friends have flipped now become
neocons i'm not even exaggerating that's
crazy they're reading they're reading
conservative military opinion about why
we must
be in the middle east and i'm like what
is what what's wrong with you
right it's pretty and that to me is very
much so like the just following orders
yep you're right well you know trump is
bad so i think it's good i was like you
know
you know do you know how many civilians
died in afghanistan last year
civilians i don't know ten thousand ten
thousand civilians we're directly
responsible for i think around six to
eight percent
our soldiers actions in the middle east
i'm not saying our soldiers are
intentionally doing that i'm saying it's
it's
and there's a lot of there's a lot of
really really crazy stories then you've
got the coalition forces it act the
number actually goes up
over the past ten years a hundred
thousand civilian deaths so when trump
is like
i'm going to put in a plan to remove our
troops i'm like well all right
okay yeah and then i see all the
establishment being like no
i'm like wait what wait when i talk to
my friends and they say
well actually i go wait what yeah the
same thing like
i i actually had an issue with you know
the whole war machine the whole
us being the the world police you know
team america
yeah it was like a funny movie that we
were
being made we were making fun of matt
stone you know trey parker they were
making fun of us for doing exactly that
and it was a it was a left position to
be against the war to be like why are we
world place why are we out
policing the world and here we go trump
is bringing it back and
sure enough everyone's like well you
know this is the confusion maybe be in
the world please isn't so bad
what what happened what where where is
your how does your mind work
and you think that you face you think
about when that thing i always bring up
where trump just blurted out we're
selling weapons
it's great for the economy yeah and all
the anti-war left was like
he just said it right and so i was
thinking about this because glenn
greenwald
is very much a progressive anti-war also
very anti-trump but he's also extremely
critical of the establishment
called that all the russiagate nonsense
and i'm thinking about this like
if you are anti-war if you know donald
uh glenn greenwald wrote this article
saying
that the establishment including liz
cheney are blocking him from pulling out
of the middle east
he wants to pull our troops out of
afghanistan and germany and they said no
and there were eight republicans and
three democrats
and i'm thinking to myself like i'm i'm
curious glenn
if you would consider supporting trump
because of this because it will get the
troops out of the middle east
and trump hasn't sent our troops at
least
yeah he hasn't sent out trump's anywhere
right like somebody who was it who wrote
at least there's no new words yeah i
think that was um
yeah some military commander was like oh
well he hasn't started any war i was i
was very critical of the tomahawk strike
in syria that trump carried out you know
a couple years ago
but my question now for these
progressives is with trump actually
trying to end this war and bring our
troops back
do is there an obligation among the left
to actually support trump
i i asked this question because we were
joking about this before
like if i were to write a punk rock song
right now yeah that was anti-war
it would the chorus would have to be
something about voting for trump
that's true like could you imagine how
insane that sounds
definitely vote vote you're playing up
his mask yeah check this out
send this over to me can you post up my
let me see
okay so so he he announced was it
yesterday or today
i think it was yesterday he said you
know what
let's wear a mask let's let's let's do
this let's uh you know i like that i
like this mask and uh
i don't mind i think it's actually a
cool match of the seal it's dope look at
that presidential seal like all right if
you're gonna wear a mask
i mean it looks it looks whatever but
now that he's announced it
how long do you think it's gonna be till
they're like oh man he's four masks
that's exactly what i
said do we do we cancel the mask thing
now
or they're gonna start saying what do we
do a study is gonna come out saying that
masks retain the virus
exactly and then when people put them on
again it increases the likelihood and
then they're going to talk about how
some family members were mixing up their
mask
their masks and spreading the infection
sounds like a real threat
you want to know something really funny
what i'm already seeing those kind of
articles
are you kidding me yeah because if you
like
i've seen an article going around about
miss proper
um after you take the mask off if you
don't if it's wet you got to clean it
you got to make sure you don't touch the
outside of it never adjust it in public
because then you're like touching the
outside of the mask and it's like
why is this coming out right now why is
this why am i
why have i never seen this until right
now what
was going on i did a video earlier on my
main channel about the democrats are
supporting the riots
yeah and that the original title i was
gonna use i said i decided not to
because i'm more of a
i'm more of a serious news personality
was
sure ingenious move democrats support
riots
because donald trump uh opposes them
like the
it was it was a play on the babylon b's
ingenious move trump
supports impeachment forcing democrats
to oppose right right
but i kid you not i called it
satire-esque the democrats right now
are actually on the side of the violent
riots
because trump wants them to stop i can't
believe it it's insane
well and people and they're they're not
calling them riots though they're
they're
stressing to everyone i i'm having these
arguments with people that are like
how how dare the feds like attack these
protesters i'm like do you have any idea
what's actually going on there
because they're they're thro they're
lighting mortars
and throwing them at the cops like in
chicago there uh
a mortar went off and actually went into
a neck of one of the police in seattle
that happened
oh it was in seattle oh you're right no
i'm sorry it was yeah fragmentation went
in the throat and neck area
he went to the hospital i don't think
he's in serious you know no it wasn't it
wasn't critical but it's like
that's happening like what are you
talking about like why what is that
what does it have to do with the feds
you are you supporting that or not do
you realize the the riots are actually
riot
the first amendment realize that
peaceful oh
i know and i talk about that too i'm
like chicago new york like all these
crazy and you know what places
murder people are getting murdered all
the time now and you know what cnn is
doing
what are they doing they're like
right-wing media is skewing the reality
of portland
and brian stelter is like of course
there's criticism for the anarchists
but it's only a 12-block radius of
violence like what
listen listen acting like right-wing
media or those that are critical of
antifa
are trying to make it seem like the
entirety of
portland is a giant fire pit of
explosions and like
like mad max and like escape from new
york and people are on like dragsters
throwing
come on man that's a straw man no we we
know that it's the downtown area and
they're taking
one building yeah no one's saying i mean
look i'll i'll i'll say this
i can't speak for any other conservative
i i can't speak for conservative media
i can speak for the whatever you want to
call it politically homeless disaffected
liberal channel that i host
where i've specifically said there are
two federal buildings under attack right
that's it and the feds are protecting
them well and
i mean that's not the only buildings
that are under attack they let the the
police station
on fire so that's burning down now the
bulk of the siege is like around one
building well the
but specifically the feds are protecting
the federal buildings
that's what they're doing and not only
that i can't i'm seeing all these videos
of the the portland police going out and
they're they're stopping people too
they're beating people portland police
put out a statement last night saying we
did not engage
any of the writers i've seen the videos
no no no last night
okay because because the democrats have
sided with the rioters
the portland police didn't come out they
specifically said everything you saw was
the feds
we have nothing to do with it so now the
portland police are like we're out
because the democrats want to support
the riots because trump opposes them
and then they go the peaceful protesters
that
earlier today peaceful protesters
smashed out a window and lobbed
mortar-style fireworks at police causing
massive explosions and damage to a
building
graffitiing everything tearing down
barricades peacefully
peaceful that's crazy and so look man
they
every video i see from my friends are
it's manipulations
yep and i had one friend saying like
dude i know people who are there they're
saying the cops are starting it and i'm
like the cops are starting it
my life my own friend said i'm in
portland like and that's not what
that's not happening and i'm like oh
you're in portland send me a video send
like if you're there like go out and
show me
you know give me information no i
haven't heard back
because they don't go downtown right and
then what cnn does is they're like the
right wing is pretending like all of
portland is on fire i'm like
i don't know about that i know that
there's one small area that's just
constant rights going on
right the same thing happened in
ferguson though and the fault is
the media in general right it's it's
just human beings you're right the media
you so i remember uh like this is true
for anywhere i talk about all the time
like when i was in egypt during the
revolution
you could literally go like three or
four blocks away and there was
mcdonald's
and you walk inside and one coke in a
cheeseburger place and they're like here
you go boom
like that and then you walk back and
you're in the revolution and people are
jumping up and down in tahrir squares of
mcdonald's right there
and there was a hilton right there i was
at the hilton i was in the balcony i'm
like at a hilton they have like steak
upstairs and they had a casino inside it
was actually kind of nice
and you look out the window there's a
revolution going on when cnn says
they're they're trying to make it seem
like everything's crazy no
you are by saying that you're lying
about
what critics are saying right they're
claiming all of portland is burning
i don't i don't recall anyone putting
out a video saying literally every city
block is on fire
knows the federal courthouse has been
besieged for 53 days
yep and probably right now the funny
thing is trump supporters are sharing
like
it's like it's like popcorn night it's
like every night you grab the popcorn
and you turn on tv to watch the riots
and the live streams and sit back and
just have a good time like they're just
watching
that's the thing yeah yeah yeah they're
like oh it's almost it's almost time
it's almost time well they're all
together as one
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you